on the anniversary of what people here
called the social explosion Chileans
were told to go home early leaving only
Riot police and a few hundred
demonstrators to clash in downtown
Santiago
it's been three years since Millions
erupted onto the streets calling for
social justice and an end to inequality
there were flagrant abuses of human
rights on the part of riot police but
also violence and vandalism violence was
considered valid as a way to shake
things
because the establishment was not
listening I would say the majority of
the country in that moment is a valid
way to sort of Awake the country that is
no longer the case and the streets are
no longer overflowing the demonstrators
I
died
why so few I ask
I think there's a degree of demotivation
because the new draft Constitution was
rejected
she's referring to last month's
referendum in which the majority of
Chileans voted against with many Saw as
a new Constitution that was too radical
the demand for social reforms continues
but inflation and Rising crime are also
now issues
left-wing president Gabriel borage
addressed the nation to remind citizens
that Chile still has an opportunity to
write a new draft Constitution and build
a foundation for a new more equal
Society
on this anniversary it's time to abandon
our comfort zone to interpret what
happened to learn the lessons from it
and act upon them the social explosion
expressed and brought with it much pain
it left many scars we won't allow it to
have been in vain
but it said that many police abusers
remain unpunished but he also admitted
that there's been a backlash against
protests because many end in violence
Riot police are outnumbering the
protesters here at least two to one and
they are constantly hurling tear gas and
water cannon that is making it very very
difficult for large numbers of people to
gather here but that is likely to change
once it gets dark especially in the
outlying neighborhoods of Santiago
expressed during the original social
Revolt remains close to the surface
how Chile's political institutions will
respond to its root causes remains
uncertain
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago